bonsoir et bienvenue en ce début de
semaine sur tv fil 78 pour une nouvelle
édition du 7 8 l'aktu le journal de la
rédaction voici les titres à guyancourt
tensions entre la ville et les
représentants des musulmans comment
expliquer cette situation de quelques
conséquences nous le verrons tout à
l'heure au cours de ce journal arman est
la manifestation culturelle permet
chaque année à montigny le bretonneux de
récolter des fonds pour lutter contre la
maladie d'alzheimer une nouvelle édition
vient de se tenir le succès était au
rendez vous après la déconvenue de l'an
passé et puis eléonore gabarain
présidente de l'association contre
l'heure d'été double sort en plateau
pour évoquer le changement d'heure donc
de ce week end et son opposition à ce
dispositif lancé afin de réaliser des
économies d'énergie l'image du jour en
attendant c'est à la verrière où le parc
du jardin de la mgen la mutuelle
générale de l'éducation nationale des
dorénavant ouvert au public la ville a
récupéré il ya peu l'accès à ce site
verrier roi vert hyéroise l'ont
découvert ce week-end seulement mauvaise
mauvaise surprise pour l'un des
riverains le gardien plus
particulièrement puisque son garage vous
le voyez a été en grillage est
impossible de rentrer ou de sortir une
clôture poser pour des raisons de
sécurité pour éviter la circulation pour
les piétons la mise en place d'un
portail aurait cependant permis d'
éviter ce désagrément ce sera chose
faite dans les plus brefs délais
apparemment en attendant voici la
réaction du gardien qui prend ça avec
philosophie
j'habite aux deux ter avenue de la gare
donc dans l'enceinte du parc
anciennement une gêne qui est ouvert
aujourd'hui et
il ya une clôture qui a été posée hier
je peux plus sortir de la voiture du
garage ni rentrer ni sortir puisque
visiblement on s'est interdit de
circuler ce qui est normal pour des
raisons de sécurité parce que c'est
ouvert au public je le comprends très
bien mais moi je paye ma taxe
d'habitation ici je comprends pas qu'on
puisse que je puisse pas sortir de mon
garage au départ la communauté
d'agglomération est venu pour voir
comment il allait clôturer il y avait un
portillon d'un mètre de prévu et ici une
barrière de quatre mètres pour pouvoir
justement sortir du garage et on
résultat il ya une clôture qui a été
fait on espère que la situation va
s'améliorer rapidement nous reviendrons
en tout cas dans quelques minutes sur
l'ouverture de ce parc est de la mgen au
public depuis l élection d'un nouveau
bureau au sein de l'association des
musulmans de guyancourt les rapports
seraient tendues avec la ville à tel
point que la municipalité a fait
diffuser un communiqué de presse pour
détailler les pointes frictions comme
nous l'expliqué catherine mulato le
torchon brûle entre la mairie de
guyancourt et l'association des
musulmans de la commune des relations
qui se seraient tendues depuis le 1er
mai dernier et l'élection d'un nouveau
bureau et d'un nouveau président une
situation si compliqué que la
municipalité a diffusé un communiqué de
presse pour dénoncer certaines méthodes
que la ville juge inadmissible jusqu'à
présent les relations avec la mg
historiquement été très bonne c'est à
dire qu'on travaille avec eux sur
beaucoup de sujets on avait signé une
convention de partenariat en particulier
pour le
l'équipement qu'ils ont à qui l'on rend
leur prêtent alors au niveau de la
mairie mais depuis ce changement de
bureau il y à des tensions
ne pas être pas acceptable de leur part
par exemple ils sont venus occuper la
mairie sont venus faire du chantage de
de prières dans la rue ils ont affiché
dans la mosquée d des tracts contre la
mairie donc nous on veut bien dialoguer
mais si le dialogue il commence par ce
genre de rapport de force on va pas
penser au coeur des tensions les travaux
d'agrandissement du lieu de culte les
permis de construire avait été posée les
tableaux devant les travaux avaient été
mis et c'est donc tout se passait dans
de bonnes conditions on leur avait
demandé de libérer les locaux pour pau à
faire les travaux ils ne l'ont pas fait
donc nous n'avons pas pu continuer ou
commencer les travaux donc les les
travaux sont actuellement arrêtés on les
rencontre pas un dialogue pas avec eux
sur ce sujet mais on souhaite que dans
l'intérêt des musulmans depuis en cours
que il est et puissent prier dans
d'excellentes conditions comme on le
fait avec eux toutes les toutes les
associations où tous les tous les lieux
cultes un membre de l'ancien bureau de
l'association sous couvert d'anonymat
déclare déploré la situation
il ajoute avant en bonne intelligence
tout se passait bien le nouveau
président de l'association des musulmans
de guyancourt joint par téléphone n'a
pas souhaité répondre à nos questions
on retourne à la verrière les habitants
de la verrière qui ont enfin leur espace
vert le parc du château autrefois
réservé aux malades de l'institut marcel
rivière le parc est désormais accessible
à tous et à toutes une convention a été
signée entre la mgen et la ville au
début du mois et c'est samedi matin que
les verts hyérois ont visité les lieux
pour la première fois à travers un
rallye découverte organisée pour
l'occasion et qu'ont suivie avec l'arc
en biais et le dis moi
ici nous sommes au parc du château à la
verrière samedi et pour la première fois
il ouvrait ses portes au public et pour
fêter cet événement une inauguration un
peu particulière un rallye découverte
sébastien et caroline sont venus en
famille participer à cette course
d'orientation pas comme les autres le
but du jeu trouvé cette balise et
répondre pour chacune d'entre elles à
une énigme ni dès le départ impossible
pour la femme isabelle de trouver la
première balle et
une seule solution retourner à l'accueil
le problème est vite réseau bon il nous
faisant renvoyer recherché ici alors que
la personne assurée là allez c'est
reparti caché derrière cet arbre ils
trouvent enfin leur première balise à
chaque étape sont et nîmes question
nature ici un peu plus loin ont fait
appel à leur culture générale qui a
dessiné le parc du château reçu des
bonnes notes et
n'entendrait de notre rivière c'est l
institut des animateurs de la ville ont
également mis la main à la pâte ici on
retrouve un compteur
à quel endroit j'étais prend de l'eau
vient alors leader exactement
donc la première équipe arrivée remettra
les sept mots deviner au fil du jeu en
mer qui devra les intégrer dans son
discours inaugural en attendant la
famille zen bell continue sa quête et
découvre peu à peu le parc moi je trouve
ça très bien que ça fait découvrir le
parc aux enfants déjà aux habitants des
verrières et ça fait un accès aux
enfants quand même au niveau de la
nature ce que j'avais dans les bâtiments
donc quand on va aller faire du vélo ou
à se promener c'est soit 20 août à
l'étang des noës soit la base de loisirs
dont c'est un peu plus lent ces quinze
hectares seront désormais ouverts tous
les jours de 8h à 18h
il suffit de regarder dehors pour s'en
convaincre l'heure d'hiver est bien
arrivé il finit beaucoup plus tôt je
reçois dans le journal ce soir et le
nord avoir un bon soir vous êtes la
présidente de l'association contre
l'heure d'été double basée à
marly-le-roi alors expliquez nous
pourquoi être contre ce changement
d'heure une mesure qui remonte à 1975
oui ça fait pas très longtemps boudé
cette rupture des nos rythmes et
biologiques et du rythme de travail est
en fait il n'y a pas de raison de leur
de suivre ces systèmes est ce qu on a vu
par différentes études et finalement on
n'économise pas de l'énergie d'un côté
il ya un peu d'éclairage qu'on économise
et d'autres côté ya des surconsommations
c'est pour l' agence de l'environnement
de l'énergie le changement d'heure
permettrait chaque année d'économiser
l'équivalent de la consommation annuelle
de 800 mille ménages français vous
n'êtes pas d'accord avec ce chiffre non
parce que si on devait dans l'ensemble
des études donc réalisé dans le monde
mais justement l'ademe c'est dans une
étude très très long et qu'on peut avoir
ne pas pas directement par
internationale lui demanda donc elle
signalé ces études et la plupart de ces
études fait main même au japon aux états
unis sera donc signalent une
augmentation de la consommation
c'est bon il ya des sous consommation
pour le chauffage et la climatisation
les trafics et nous associations nous
avons demandé et qu'on évalue donc les
les surcoûts pour la climatisation des
véhicules puisque on sort du travail est
presque au maximum de chaleur de la
journée parce que c'est néfaste pour la
santé est également oui oui franchement
parce que vous savez le sommeil est une
des événements très importants de l'être
humain on commence à comprendre les
mystères de sommeil mais pas pour tous
en tout cas si on si on respectait pas
une dune durée journalière d'environ 8
heures pour la moyenne des personnes et
biens on est fatigués et on est moins
performant aussi bien au niveau
intellectuel et que niveau physique et
puis on peut aussi manqué d'attention au
volant pour la vie de tous les jours
mais mal maison et il ya un surcoût et
un surcroît d'accidents toute la
circulation est aussi au niveau du
travail c'était une étude assez récente
et aux états unis parmi ces différents
risques un hausse des accidents du
travail vous l'avez mentionné ça
augmenterait le risque d'entrée dans la
maladie d'alzheimer aussi oui expliqué
oui oui oui c'est cécile le professeur
bégaud donc et en français et qui a
soulevé cette question
d'une part quand on ne dort pas bien
malheureusement souvent on vient
consommer des somnifères des somnifères
des synthèses et qui sont pas donc non
personnellement j'ai plein de choses à
base des plantes etc c'est beaucoup plus
pour bourges est commandable il faut les
payer de sa poche et est appelée
ddc spécialistes allemands ont signalé
que la simple réduction du temps de
sommeil fermenté les risques des
maladies d'alzheimer et aussi des du
diabète
concernant la santé celle des animaux
également à thoiry et le passage à
l'heure d'hiver n'a pas échappé à nos
amis les bêtes les animaux ont ils
étaient perturbés par ce secteur en
moins dans leur repas ou dans leur
sommeil olivier maniscalco elodie moines
ce week-end c'était le passage à l'heure
d'hiver et nous avons tous reculer nos
montres d'une heure à thoiry pas
d'exception les repas des animaux et la
rentrée dans les enclos arriver donc une
heure plus tard mais les tigres
antilopes et girafes ont leur propre
horloge biologique est réglée sur le
soleil alors au final ce changement
d'heure ne provoque pas de grosses
perturbations chez nos amis les bêtes
juste quelques adaptations notamment
pour les éléphants qui dodelinent de la
tête par signe de mécontentement le
changement d'heure pour les éléphants
c'est parce que nous on leur inculque
des habitudes dont ils sont là à
attendre pour rentrer parce qu'ils
comprennent pas on a une heure de retard
alors mais alors est assez indifférent
comme les autres animaux ceux qui ont
leur nourriture qui les attend la maison
ils mettront deux trois jours à repérer
la nouvelle règle et voilà c'est pas
puisqu'une dans autre chose c'est nous
qui sommes cavs ont perdu les habitudes
de nos horloges biologiques pas les
animaux l'instinct animal reste aussi un
bon indicateur saisonniers pour savoir
si l'hiver sera rude il suffit
d'observer les ours plus le terrier
qu'il creuser profond et plus l'hiver
sera rude alors si vous souhaitez
consulter météo ours et en apprendre un
peu plus sur nos amis terrestre sachez
qu'il vous reste jusqu'au 11 novembre
prochain pour circuler en voiture dans
la réserve yvelinoise avant la
traditionnelle trêve hivernale
nous évoquons le changement d'heure sur
ce plateau avec notre invité eléonore
gabarain présidente de l'association
contre l'heure d'été double pourquoi
l'heure d'été double parce que déjà un
hiver notre heure est avancée d'une
heure par rapport à l'air haleur du
fuseau géographique de la france qui est
celui de les décrire wilson centré
autour du méridien de greenwich et en
été nous allons à voir donc nous fait
nous venons d'avoir deux heures de danse
et c'est une situation assez
exceptionnelle normalement l'heure d'été
c'est une heure d'avancé par rapport aux
fuseaux et en europe actuellement il ya
l'espagne la france et le benelux et qui
ont ce système pour les benelux s'est
pas vraiment deux heures ils sont treize
ans à l'est et les voilà que l'espagne
est en train d'étudier impossible le
retour à l'heure des greens guise alors
est ce que ça va faire réfléchir nos
responsables du zoo a bavé en fait ils
vont ils vont se rattacher à leur fusion
graphique ne sommes pas des fuseaux
horaires puisqu'on est insuffisant moi
je préfère parler des zones de temps
donc pour resigner pour
donc mes référer à la zone à l'intérieur
de laquelle on a donc la même heure donc
tous les pays qui s'était engagé dans
l'association depuis 1984 présidente
depuis 1989 si les choses ont évolué ce
que vous avez obtenu des évolutions
depuis que vous mener ce combat est pas
beaucoup mais on a obtenu plusieurs
rapports vous savez en france et
plusieurs rapports parlementaires des
deux puits de député un sénateur
on bricole préconiser l'abandon pur et
simple des changements d'heure avec donc
l'heure des avancées d'une seule air en
hiver et même il ya eu d un sénateur qui
a proposé et a fait voter à prouver donc
là l'adoption en france et du système de
retraite est simple anglais c'est-à-dire
en hiver avoir l'heure de greenwich et
en été l'heure de berlin donc ces
rapports et vient l'actualité puis en
europe et aussi on nous a en deçà à
dumont entendu communiqué des rapports
il ya eu un dialogue qui étaient très
bons surtout à l'époque où monsieur
jacques delors était président de la
commission et il avait une cabine est
très ouvert et ensuite les diallo s'est
détérioré de plus en plus hélas quelques
évolutions vous souhaitez aujourd'hui
vous souhaitez qu'on se base sur
quelques réglages quels réglages sur l
idéal
bel idéal dit pour qu'il se serait alors
du fuseau pourquoi parce que les
horreurs qui nous connaissons
actuellement père simple pour l'école
est passée sont ceux et qui se sont
instaurées est donc à l'époque où la
france avait avait soit l'heure solaire
dans chaque point où l'heure du fuseau
et y appelait donc nous partirons pas
varié et voilà que maintenant nous
sommes mis à avancer il rallie vers 2
heures en été mais l'os à défaut d'avoir
leur du fuseau bon au moins avoir une
heure sans structure et moi pourquoi pas
une heure avancée de l'année comme on
avait entre 45 et 60 16 puisque le
français s'accommoder bien moi j'ai vécu
en espagne et enfin pour pendant ma
jeunesse et aussi pour personnes se
plaignaient alors vous dites des heures
en été c'est exceptionnel et c'est une
situation inégale par rapport aux autres
pourquoi nous nous n'aurions pas nous
n'aurions pas le même système que parce
qu'une heure d'avancé ça un résultat
énergétique et l'ademe n'en parler
jamais et cedar des biens de dire qui la
première et la deuxième heure d'avancé
ont des effets énergétiques qui s'ajoute
vous allez continuer ce combat pendant
encore longtemps dans le détail elle
j'espère au moins cinq ou sept ans et
puis je voudrais écrire un livre et j'ai
l'an dernier avait rédigé un rapport
j'ai tout vu sur internet sur notre blog
et est bon sur la base de ces rappels
vous allez faire une fausse un peu plus
légère un peu plus amusant parce que
j'ai beaucoup d'anecdotes a donc
l'argent compte et
venons donc d'aimer des mes voyages en
europe ou des mes relations avec le
gouvernement les députés juste une toute
dernière question ce changement d'heure
a une incidence sur votre façon de vivre
au quotidien aussi sur votre santé ce
que vous ressentez des changements
moment de changer d'heure ce week end on
a changé d'heure ça a une incidence
mieux dormi et je m'endormis
certainement puis j'aime bien le matin à
mi matinée et il ya déjà pas mal de
soleil et bois le soir ça me gêne pas
beaucoup qu'il fasse nuit plutôt des
toutes manières venir en hiver les la
durée du jour va se réduire jusqu'à 8
heures
etc ca c est surtout à donc à cette
réduction de la lumière naturelle et
qu'il faut attribuer l'augmentation des
accidents des piétons à cette époque
déjà la sécurité pas seulement au
firmament voici les changements a
certainement un effet mauvais mais si
vous aidez nous sommes quand ces
chargements mais pas deux heures
d'avancé toute l'année on aurait des
matinées telle est récent pour moi dès
décembre merci d'être venu sur ce
plateau eléonore gabarain présidente de
l'association contre l'heure d'été
double merci à vous on va parler de la
maladie d'alzheimer
arman est qui est de retour c'est la
manifestations culturelles et
caritatives proposé par le lions club
des trois villages annulé l'année
dernière la faute d'exposants cette
année à montigny ils étaient une
trentaine près de 4000 euros ont été
reversés au profit d'associations en
faveur de la lutte contre alzheimer et
contre le handicap et quatre nuls à taux
et le dis moi
la manifestation n'avait pas pu se tenir
l'année dernière faute d'un nombre
important de participants cette fois
arman est proposé à montigny le
bretonneux par le lion's-club des trois
villages est revenu avec une trentaine
d'exposants les artistes jouent leur
stand 130 euros par espace nous sommes
totalement reversés au profit des
malades d'alzheimer ou des personnes en
situation de handicap
c'est toujours intéressant de d'exposer
son travail en plus au bénéfice d'une
oeuvre comme alzheimer donc par exemple
cette année je suis rares man et nous
avons voulu que gironde icap soit
présent
car depuis plusieurs années nous avons
donné donc les dons âgées handicap est
géré handicapés sont investis dans le
dans différentes actions dont ultime
snack salle snow hélène qui est le sale
justement pour aider les personnes
atteintes de l'alzheimer
grâce aux dons du lion's-club gérondi
cap basée à manille les âmes on va
pouvoir démarrer un atelier de peinture
pour les malades d'alzheimer ce n'est
pas tout l'association a aussi d'autres
projets actuellement gérant du cac
travail sur tout un plan d'action pour
les personnes aidantes avec les entrées
dans café un mardi sur deux au café le
marina des ateliers pratiques et
thématiques qui ont lieu quelques fois
au domaine du maire en terre et des
groupes de paroles si les dons peuvent
permettre de participer à la poursuite
de ces ateliers ça sera déjà un très bon
bénéfice pour pour les personnes en deux
jours harman et aura permis de collecter
quelques 4000 euros qui viendront donc
au soutien aux associations qui aident
les personnes malades d'alzheimer et les
personnes en situation de handicap l'an
prochain les organisateurs espèrent
doubler le nombre d'exposants
12 km dans la boue sur un parcours semé
d'embûches pont de singe fils a grimpé
encore tubes à franchir la frappadingue
c'est le nom de ce rendez-vous qui vient
de se dérouler au cours du week-end
c'était dans les yvelines après
montreuil sur mer courchevel ou encore
sedan cette étape a fédéré près de 2000
amateurs de sensations fortes et qui
n'avait pas peur de salir vous allez le
voir en tony rocci le diwan
le soleil s'est levé il y à peine une
heure à mon talent et le bois dans les
yvelines il sa masse sur la ligne de
départ encore propres et déchaîné avant
ça
des entraînements de commandos d'élite
les 12 km de la frappadingue sont semées
d'obstacles
non non c'est génial on a roulé dans la
boue quoi c'est tout pardon place à sap
et charlotte au menu barbelés
électrifiés bain de boue en fortune elle
a rempli d'eau et tout cela dans une
ambiance de carnaval mais il y a quatre
ans dans le pas de calais l'état
d'esprit de la frappadingue celle
entraide et le dépassement de soi qui
prennent le pas sur la compétition et
tout le monde est chronométré mais voilà
le but c'est une grosse déconnade on a
cette particularité d'avoir 90 % des
participants sont les inciter sans une
toux qui viennent déguisés ils savent
qu'ils sont là pour passer une très
bonne journée d'efforts physiques les
choses comme ça ça reste physique et le
gars à l'arrivée vous verrez se sont
laissés vacants et quand on devient
addict à la course d'obstacles à
l'arrivée la boue les barbelés ne
suffisent plus ni un petit suc et pas
assez d'eau mais sinon c'était très
sympa beaucoup trop chaud après c'était
ici
on en reparle dans ce
sens et à la fin ce qui compte c'est de
l'avoir fait la médaille de la
frappadingue vaut bien plus que dans les
autres compétitions il était 2300 a
dévalé les 12 km de la course yvelinoise
il était courageux effectivement
toujours en sport un mode échec c'est
plus traditionnel le tournoi des maîtres
la dame noire à montigny le bretonneux
premier tournoi organisé pour le club
local nous avions suivi et la semaine
dernière julien saada long des 200
meilleurs français alors de ses
premières parties à l'issue de la
compétition il réalise sa première norme
une distinction particulière qui lui
ouvre les portes au titre de maître
international même s'il reste encore
toute une série d'épreuves à relever
julien salah se classe au final le 3e 3e
donc au général derrière les
représentants de la bulgarie et de
l'azerbaïdjan sur le podium tout au long
de la semaine dans le 7-8 lac tu nous
nous attarderons sur la fête d'halloween
on pensait ce rendez-vous qui marquait
la fin du mois d'octobre en perte de
vitesse en france et pourtant il fait
toujours recette vous le verrez à
travers une série de reportages à
découvrir dès demain mardi mais déjà
vous avez la parole allez vous fêter
halloween cette semaine si oui de quelle
manière voici vos réponses avec ce micro
trottoir pas vraiment puisque l'on
connaît pense pas
dans nos habitudes
familiales
et mon petit fils il est venu passer
quelques jours mais on ne pratique pas
halloween
ouais je
veux sortir dehors pour prendre
pour franck devant vous ils vont
peut-être se déguiser on aura des
bonbons à disposition si ça sonne à la
porte non j'ai pas fêter halloween et
c'est ma petite nièce donc elle va fêter
halloween axé son papa et sa maman on a
déjà fait la citrouille mais la capuche
la citrouille et puis on va chercher des
bonbons pour pas tellement peut-être au
peut-être ils vont peut-être se déguiser
mais met un petit masque c'est tout quoi
c'est l'occasion pour les enfants de se
déguiser s'amusent à se faire peur
les enfants et les adultes aussi on n'en
doute pas qu'ils vont se déguiser en
rendez vous demain pour le premier volet
de notre série de reportages dédiés
halloween c'est la fin de ce journal je
vous retrouve mardi pour un nouveau
point complet sur l'actualité locale ce
lundi soir vous pourrez suivre le 7-8
sport avec anthony rech excellente
soirée